hi everyone I'm here with Ron caner a
Messianic Jewish Communicator here in
Israel how you doing Ron I'm doing great
thank you now to kind of get the obvious
out of the way you're sounding awfully
American to me yes I was born in
Virginia um I'm Jewish I had a radical
experience when I was 18 years old in a
car in the middle of North Carolina
praying after seeing a movie about Jesus
which is strange enough that a Jewish
young man was at a movie about Jesus but
I was searching for God I was searching
for truth and I just said God I have to
know I have to know is it Jesus Judaism
both I don't understand explain it to me
and as I was praying my friend lost
control of the car it spun around
several times flipped over upside down
in the middle of nowhere but there was
one house and inside those house were
two Believers with uh a copy of evidence
that demands a verdict by Josh mcdal and
by the end of them talking to me uh I
was having having a supernatural
encounter with God who revealed to me
Jesus Yeshua and I became a
Believer now um what uh obviously there
are lots of Jews who don't come to that
same conclusion so what would why do you
why do you believe that that Jesus is
the Messiah well uh I first of all he
fulfilled the prophecy the book they
gave me evidence that demands a verdict
Josh McDow is a brilliant apologist uh
and one of the things you see is that
Yeshua Jesus fulfilled so many
prophecies it would be impossible for it
not to be him he was born in Bethlehem
uh if you just look if you just take
Isaiah 53 and rejected by his own people
uh gives his life for his own people he
is buried with the w with the rich
Joseph of ARA takes his body with
Nicodemus uh with Sinners he dies on a
Roman cross which was the way you killed
bad people and he would see the light of
life again he he rose from the dead so
he fulfilled the prophecies now for me
at the time none of that I KN I didn't
know any of that what I had was an
encounter with God and uh that was
enough for me but what happened see at
that time I said well I'm I'm I'm now a
Christian I'm no longer Jewish I have I
don't know what's happened to me and I
began to read the Bible the the biggest
shock for me David is as I'm reading the
New Testament I everyone's Jewish like I
had no idea there's a guy named John the
Baptist who's actually not Baptist but
Jewish he was a Jewish Prophet Paul the
Apostle was actually a Jewish rabbi
Peter J like I had no idea they were all
Jewish and the big controversy in the
New Covenant
wasn't can Jewish people believe that
Jesus is the Messiah all of the
Believers were Jewish it was when Peter
begins to preach to Gentiles in fact in
Acts chapter 10 when the Holy Spirit
falls on the Gentiles they begin to pray
in tongues Peter what does it he say who
can stop these Gentiles from being
baptized in water see it's no
controversy today if I take we're right
near the Mediterranean Sea right over
there if I take some Gentiles over there
to bapti that's not controversial but if
I take a Jewish person that's taboo
that's a big deal but during the times
just after Jesus rose from the dead of
the New Covenant baptizing Gentiles that
was the controversial thing and of
course we know in Acts 15 they have a
big uh uh the first church Council if
you will and they said all right
Gentiles don't have to become Jewish to
believe in do you understand that no
Jewish person well not no but almost no
Jewish people understand that acts 15 is
actually part of the New Testament
history that they wanted to tell the
Gentiles okay you can believe in the
Messiah But first you have to convert to
Judaism now what they they say is if
you're Jewish like me in order to
believe you have to leave Judaism and I
discovered very quickly that I'm still
Jewish and I live as a Jew I live here
in the land of the Jews and I am uh I
have a relationship with Yeshua Jesus
the Messiah and it's interesting that
you brought up Isaiah 53 because uh I
interact a lot with Muslims and I've
heard some very similar stories of
people
who read Isaiah 53 Christians who read
read Isaiah 53 to Jews and I've heard I
have I have a friend named Tony who's
got some Jewish in-laws and he said he
uh he read Isaiah 53 to his Jewish
in-laws and they said stop reading the
New Testament to us we only believe we
only I'll I'll tell you a true story I
was on an airplane I used to be a a
sales manager in a radio station and I
had a guy who worked for me he was 80
years old but he a great salesman and we
were on our way to a conference on an
airplane and I had been sharing with him
and I read to him from Isaiah 53 three
he cursed at me and he said stop reading
from the New Testament wow and that's
the reason I find that uh interesting is
I've had that experience with Muslims
when um I would read to them Isaiah 53
and then say who's this talking about
and they go Jesus but we don't we don't
believe in we don't believe in the New
Testament like wait a minute that's
that's actually Old Testament uh but
another thing that I that I find
interesting is uh um because certain
prophecies are known to kind of you know
any Christian who gets into apologetics
will be familiar with some of the
prophecies
but a a lot of the Messianic Believers
go go way deeper than than most people
in apologetics are aware of and I I I
found this out in a debate on uh Faith
Under Fire between Michael Brown and
Rabbi schmi boak and and and I I we we
did a live stream with uh with Rabbi
schle a while back but um uh and and
just the the level that they were were
uh debating on going into very minute
details yes uh in the prophets and so on
just was just fascinating it's like this
this actually goes uh much deeper than
than most Christians are uh aware of so
yeah this is uh this is um lots of lots
of stuff for Muslims and and Christians
and and Jews to consider uh but now
we're we're actually in ashalon right
now right in Israel and what what what
what made you want to move over here
to Israel or to ashalon uh either one uh
well ashalon I'm here because my
mother-in-law is getting older and we
moved here uh the funny thing is we
moved here just a few months ago and
then October the 7th happened a war
breaks out they mve my mother-in-law
because she's 84 years old and she
doesn't moov well to a wonderful uh we
call it beta an old age home in Tel Aviv
and my wife and I were stuck here with
the Rockets um but we moved to Israel my
wife is a native born Israeli uh she
came to Faith uh a couple years after I
did and
um and we just always knew that you know
eventually we would make our way back
here to Israel so in 2003 uh we moved
here with our three daughters and but
we've lived in the Tel Aviv area uh
during most of that time and but but let
me just go a little bit deeper the real
reason is the prophecies in the Bible
the Bible talks about the Jewish people
in the end times not only coming to
Faith but coming back to this land
there's two things that are going to
happen coming back to this land and
coming back to faith in God or I believe
in Yeshua so we uh we wanted to reach
our people so we came back here we have
a Ministry called shelanu TV which is a
247 Hebrew language gospel channel that
plays uh here in the land and you know
Facebook and Tik Tok and and all the
social media reaching Jewish people
Israelis with the message of Yeshua and
it's interesting interesting because uh
you moved here but just also I mean this
is my second trip to Israel and I've
been here for about a week and I've just
met a lot of people who you know you you
just hear their accent like hey you're
you're from you know you're from America
what what's going on it's just lots of
lots of Jews are are uh are are moving
back here and um that's uh that that
brings up an issue of what it would what
it's like to be a Jewish believer in
Jesus here in Israel because as soon as
I mention that I'm going to Israel I get
all of these messages uh usually from
Muslims but also uh from some Christians
right saying uh you better not wear your
cross or let them know you're Christian
because you're going to get beat up and
uh everyone says that I'm going to get
spit upon and I've been wearing this
cross nonstop for a week and I've been
um I've been at the West Western Wall I
went to Michael rapaport's Bar Mitzvah
uh I was in there we went under we went
under the uh under the Western Wall area
to the archaeological site and went
through there and we came out and we're
in the area that's like prohibited for
non-jews but I was just kind of part of
the group and I've been wearing a cross
the entire time no one has so much as
looked at me wrong yeah for for wearing
a cross and when I say when I say that
they say they they post videos of you
know some some group of
like Ultra Orthodox Jews who like spit
on Christians as they walk by and so
what's going on there that is um that's
1% of 1% it's just like an tiny minority
a tiny minority and and you say well why
why do we see them because it's not news
if I don't spit on you if I don't
persecute you nobody's going to film me
and put it on YouTube but if something
crazy happens that's what we we all film
and we put on online but I've lived here
for 20 years and uh I've been rejected
exactly two times for my faith in each
time it was not violent at all the first
time I was at the Western Wall I was
filming a four-part series on The Six
Day War and uh at the end of the last uh
uh episode there was just unusual just
God was there and I could feel it I
could see a a a crowd gathering around
us and I I was just hoping I wouldn't
mess up because we were using a
teleprompter and as I finished a rabbi
walks up to me with his wife and
children and he says would you come to
our synagogue and give sermons and I
said well I would love to I said but I
think there's something you need to know
about me first and that was the end of
the conversation um that that actually
reminds me like in the Bible and they
hey Paul why don't you come preach here
that's interesting exactly um and and
unfortunately we did suffer one violent
attack and it was it was recently but
again it was from this Fringe group we
had a prayer meeting there was three
weeks of prayer and fasting for Israel
Christians all over the world
participated back in May and we ended uh
right outside the Western on the
southern steps with a prayer meeting and
as my and and unfortunately there are
some people who are bad guys Bad actors
and the one of the Deputy mayors of
Jerusalem called for a protest was say
deputy mayor you have 10 Deputy Mayors
one some are leftwing some are right
from all over the Spectrum this guy's a
radical he called for people to come out
and protest and uh police had to help
people get in again it wasn't super
violent but it was it was aggressive but
my wife came in after the police had
left and after everyone else had left
and unfortunately she she was beaten up
by by some older
teenagers and uh you know her testimony
is that while they were hitting her uh
it was almost like she could she was
watching it and Yeshua Jesus was
standing with her saying this is what
they did to me but not in a accus but
pray for them love them care for them
they they like Jesus said you know
father forgive them they don't know what
they're doing but again that is 1% of 1%
the vast majority of Jewish people that
I meet that I share with they're
intrigued when I tell them that I'm
Jewish that I believe in Yeshua Jesus
they want to know how I came to this
conclusion yeah and the interesting part
here is that the vast majority of people
who say watch out David because they're
going to beat you up or they're going to
spit on you or something like that
they're the exact same people who after
every terrorist attack carried out in
the name of Islam uh from boo Haram from
al-shabab from Hamas from Hezbollah from
uh Al-Qaeda uh Isis the Taliban after
every attack it's don't associate this
with any other Muslims but these same
exact people will say either uh here's
here's a you know here's here's a Ultra
Orthodox Jewish guy spitting on
Christians therefore that's the way Jews
are and this is what's going to happen
to you or they will say here's something
that a Jewish rabbi said in the seventh
century and therefore that's what all
Jews believe and so uh so watch out
right the vast majority of Jewish people
I actually don't care what I believe in
fact I remember I was here with a tour
group and this sweet fellow from the
south uh in in America he walked up to a
Jewish girl another tourist from America
from New York and said uh you know
started to share the gospel with her and
she just looked up and said
congratulations and just kept walking
she didn't care uh you know I would hope
they would care more but the idea that
Jewish people are activ actively violent
against me because of my faith is just
ridiculous and one quick question along
those lines you're in ashalon that's
that's fairly close to Gaza uh what do
you as a Jewish believer in Jesus what
would you consider a greater threat to
your and your family's safety uh Jews in
Israel or Hamas well that's for for
someone living here that's a very easy
question question to answer um I see
Rockets go over my house uh from Hamas
I've not again other than that one
incident my wife went through and and it
wasn't it wasn't a great thing that she
went through and uh it was very
difficult but it was one time in 20
years we've watched hundreds of rockets
literally fly over ashdot is right over
there I watch the Iron Dome go up and
take them out they are actively
seeking if they could they would kill
all of us and when I say they I don't
mean every Palestinian I don't mean
every Arab we love the Arab people we
want to reach them with the
gospel I'm talking about Hamas which is
a terrorist organization and sadly even
in all all throughout Gaza you look at
the UN and their schools there they're
actively teaching anti-Semitism so if
you're a two-year-old kid a
three-year-old kid growing up in Gaza
you don't have a chance to Simply see
the world as it is you were taught from
the time you Jews are bloodthirsty Jews
want to kill you they want to rape you
but it's actually was Hamas who actually
raped our daughters on October the 7th
gang raped them uh shot them in the head
left them others left for dead shot them
in the pelvises it's it is
unconscionable what they did and what's
amazing David I thought really after
October 7th I thought now they're going
to understand now the world is going to
understand what we live with they're
understand why we have to be tough why
we have to have fences and borders cuz
they want to kill us and it was like
that for about 10 minutes M it was the
next day October 8th I think in Harvard
where they were already protesting
against before we even responded they're
supporting the rapist and the murderers
so in answer to your question Hamas is
there terrorist organization yeah
and you're talking about how uh how how
people view um Jews and it just seems
like so radically different as I
mentioned that if Muslims do something
it's hey don't blame Muslims but if a
Jew does something ah we got to and like
all the rules suddenly go out the window
as soon as Jews are involved and I was I
was uh in an interview the other day and
he would you know someone was the the
interviewer was asking me uh why I would
support Israel in this conflict and you
know when I'm a Christian and so on and
I gave I said I said probably 20
different reasons and I gave some
examples and and one of them was just
like there seems to be this like demonic
obsession with Jews and right when I say
that people are going to say well maybe
it's because the Jews are doing this
stuff and so and it's but it's not that
it's that they're there's constant lying
about them involved there's utter
hypocrisy any rule that applies to
anyone else in the world suddenly goes
out the window when we're talking about
Jews right and you wonder why and I I
couldn't think of another example I said
look if if I if I saw a horde of demons
going after a squirrel and I had no idea
what anything else was about I'd be like
well if if the the demons are going
after the squirrel I I just have I have
a sudden urge to to go to protect the
squirrel and it's it's it's kind of a
feeling like that but there is a I do
want from a Christian perspective
because there are different Christian
perspectives on uh you know Jews being
in the land and whether they lost any
sort of divine right to the land I'm not
I'm not I don't even think about this in
terms I think of this in like human
rights and so on right and uh the like
resilience of the Jewish people and so
on so I'm thinking and like Jews
actually needing a place because I would
say they had an airtight case for
needing a place where they can protect
themselves after World War II and then
after decades go by you think ah but
we've moved past that and I you just saw
recently how things can flip on the drop
of a dime and people on hit people on uh
Twitter start Twitter and Tik Tok start
celebrating Hitler and saying maybe
Hitler was right and Bin Laden suddenly
a poet yeah yeah he's suddenly he's
suddenly a brilliant wonderful guy and
it's it's like no really seems like
people's opinion can can switch like
that and so uh but but what is your
perspective on because Christians do
have uh different perspectives but as
far as Jews being in the land of of
Israel well before I share on that let
me just say something about what you
said before I I saw a video yesterday on
Twitter the video was Israeli soldiers
eating food they were happy there was
Joy there was good morale and the person
who posted it wrote the zionists are
inhumane what she meant is how how can
they eat and be happy what she doesn't
understand is that the war you know
where you are geographically David it's
10 minutes that way in 10 minutes I can
be at the border of Gaza so the food
that they're eating is coming from
people like me from the rest of Israel
who are going to our scared troops who
don't want to be there who don't want to
be risking their lives but are willing
to because they witness October the 7th
and we bring food in we bring dessert in
we say we love you we're with you we're
praying for you and they're happy that's
inhumane according to that's how they
twist everything around but but in terms
of you know Jewish people being in the
land I'm I am a Zionist I believe and
what do I mean by that because Zionist
has suddenly become like this this
four-letter word it's this evil word oh
and let me let me just say right there
because um in the past I thought of
Zionist as someone who believes that
Jews have a divine right to this land
and so in the past I'd say well I'm not
a I'm not a Zionist because I don't know
I don't know about Divine again I'm
thinking in terms of like human rights
and so on whereas now it seems like a is
anyone who thinks that Israel has a
right to defend itself against against
uh against terrorist attacks so uh just
tell us what you mean and well I am a
Biblical Zionist I believe that God's
promises to Abraham regard he said
forever in Hebrew forever you know
there's no other words that we have for
that or
uh which means literally forever and
ever these promises were made in the
Bible so either God is a liar or exactly
what the prophet said would happen has
happened which is we were disciplined as
a people we were scattered all over the
world all over the world Ezekiel said
I'm going to bring you back from all the
lands where I have scattered you that
was more than Babylon that's just one
land but we were scattered after 708 all
over the world and here there are 7
million Jews back in this country living
it's a beautiful country as you've seen
you know we're we're productive we're so
productive that our enemies want to make
peace with us not because they like Jews
but because they want our technology the
Abraham Accords that has nothing to do
with with the UAE liking us it's them
wanting to make money and Saudi Arabia
wants to make peace with us and Saudi
Arabia does not care about by the way
they don't care about Palestinians they
don't care about Jews they care about
making money and that's why they want to
make peace with Israel so I believe that
us being here today the Jewish people
it's a fulfillment of Prophecy but I
could argue it just on a humanitarian
level that like you said after the
Holocaust it was clear to everyone that
we as a people will never be safe in
Europe we'll never be safe in the
Americas we'll never be safe any and you
know what I lived in America most of my
life till I was 38 years old and
honestly I thought well anti-Semitism
will never take hold here well October
the 7th happens and it's it's mainstream
you can say things on Twitter or any
other social media horrible things about
the Jewish people that if you had said
it on October SE 6 people would have
called you an anti-semite now you're a
humanitarian so on a humanitarian level
we have nowhere else to go now
understand that the Arab Nations that
you know today Iraq Lebanon Jord they're
all new nations these are not the it's
it's Arabia the Arab people are one
people scattered throughout North Africa
in and and and all over the Middle East
and after World War I they cut up this
whole area and they created all these
new nations but they are they're they're
Arabs and again we're not anti-arab we
would love to live at peace with the
Arabs but you have to not look at this
situation as uh Israel as this aggressor
we're a tiny SLI just go go look at your
map we're a tiny sliver of land about
the size of New Jersey surrounded right
by New Jersey surrounded by
99% plus of Arabs or Persians and many
of them would love to see us dead so we
have to be strong or we will not exist
as a
people and so uh that that's pretty much
everything I wanted to talk about but
for people who want to know
more where would they go uh ron.com
that's r n c n
t.com and of course we're on all the
social media sites and uh shalot tv.com
if you want to learn more about our TV
network all right thanks brother thank
you David God bless
you
[Music]